la vraie actualité du Sahel va être
désormais évidemment la résurgence
massive du risque terroriste massive
quand je dis massive c'est euh euh
potentiellement euh euh se retrouver
dans une situation dans lequelle il
pourrait y avoir une partition du Mali
euh dans les semaines dans les mois qui
viennent donc nous remettre dans une
situation qui serait celle au fond euh
avant que le président Hollande ne
prenne la décision de lancer Serval puis
Barkan c'est une réalité il faut
regarder c'est pas la faute de la France
contrairement à ce que certains
racontent je ve dire je crois que moi je
l'ai dit de nombreuses reprises
l'occasion d'IR parler avec le
présidentand il y a pas très longtemps
tout ça ce sont de bonnes décisions qui
ont été prises enfin la réalité c'est
que les Maliens ont fait le choix de
préférer Wagner pas les Maliens non pas
les pas les Maliens la jeinte Malienne
pardonnez-moi parce que les Maliens sont
les premières victimes de ce qui se
passe la jeinte Malienne a fait le choix
de de de préserver son pouvoir et ses
avantages euh en ayant recours à Wagner
plutôt qu'à l'armée française